Disney are actually technically a Hong
Kong based company called Manta lab but
who cares about being specific well they
released a collector's steelbook for One
Division and surprise it doesn't even
have a disc in it but double surprise I
actually don't think that's that big a
deal these specific types of Steel books
aren't really official mainstream
releases they're made by third-party
companies for a very specific type of
collector they're meant to be display
pieces on their shelving and are often
kept in their wrapping four best quality
purposes there's actually quite a good
amount of collector steelbooks out there
that don't have discs it's cheaper to
make and most people have the mainstream
release already these things are
expensive and so naturally incredibly
Niche that they often only make like a
thousand total the only real issue here
is just that well one division doesn't
have any physical release and yeah so
that sucks and that's on Disney but
please let the collector steal book
weirdos enjoy their little boxes